i did what i had to do to protect our world
Things just got out of hand
you break the rules and become
a hero it doesn't seem fair
We should tell him the truth
Welcome back everyone
this is going to be my doctor strange 2 video
for how marvel is bringing x-men in the mcu there
have been four different trailers they've released
for this movie so far and they all have slightly
different footage with different easter eggs and
references for x-men and mutants so we'll break
it all down welcome to the mcu professor x and all
the x-men you're bringing with you we also have to
thank scarlet witch and doctor strange for messing
with the multiverse so much thank you for wrecking
the multiverse so bad that now we're getting x-men
speaking of wrecking the multiverse so bad
that other characters from other franchises
come to the mcu we're doing a giveaway for that
spider-man no way home blu-ray there's so many
extra toby mcguire andrew garfield matt murdock
daredevil scenes cannot wait to check that out
all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and let me know which x-men characters besides
patrick stewart's professor x you want to see
come back to the mcu from the fox marvel movies
patrick stewart is really just the tip of
that x-men spear and just to be clear when
i'm talking about how x-men come into the mcu
properly in this video i'm talking about the core
x-men characters but also kind of mutants just
in general we've actually had mutants in the
mcu before the events of doctor strange ii which
i'll explain some of you already probably know
what i'm talking about there patrick stewart's
professor x is just the first legit core x-men
character that's appeared on screen in a marvel
mcu movie from the fox marvel movies i'll explain
where scarlet witch quicksilver and billy and
tommy fall on the spectrum of mutants and x-men
characters canonically in the mcu mcu scarlet
witch is canonically viewed as a mutant in the mcu
not an x-men character she was created in the
classic x-men comics in the 1960s but she wasn't
really on the x-men team for any extended period
of time and she was only featured in a couple of
x-men the animated series episodes later animated
series featuring the x-men so just in general
in pop culture she's not really viewed as
a core x-men team member even though she
appears in some of the seminal x-men stories
like house of m and i will talk about that too
because i do think that scarlet witch will be
a big part of how they bring x-men to the mcu
during wandavision some of you probably picked
up on the fact that they finally officially
canonized scarlet witch as a mutant on the dl
it was really subtle they didn't say the word
a mutant out loud but they did clarify that
she was born with her powers quicksilver too
she always had her chaos magic abilities the mind
stone just deepened her access to her powers more
fully it didn't mutate her biology any more than
it already was in order to be considered a mutant
you have to be born with your powers that's why
scarlet witch quicksilver billy and tommy are all
mutants in the mcu but spider-man and the hulk
for instance who have biologically based powers
are not mutants they're called mutates the
fantastic four comic book deadpool not the ryan
reynolds version of deadpool in monica rambo
now after the events of wandavision are mew
tates i say comic book deadpool not ryan reynolds
deadpool because in the first deadpool movie they
actually talk about him being born with the x
gene so when ryan reynolds deadpool comes to
the mcu via the multiverse he will be a mutant
any tips on getting into the mcu there cork
mutates are people who got their powers later
in life after their biology was mutated by some
accident or process like the radioactive spider
bite biting peter parker mutated his biology
giving him his powers the difference between x-men
and mutants is that x-men have to be born with the
x gene specifically or they have to have been part
of the core x-men team or roster for a long time
so you could be a mutant but not an x-men but
all x-men are mutants i talked a little bit about
the x-men movie that kevin feige and the marvel
people are developing inside the mcu it's going
to be a couple years before it comes out but
the working title for that is now just called
the mutants that doesn't mean that they're not
ever going to use the x-men name inside the mcu
the title the mutants was what stan lee originally
called the x-men comic book before he finished
developing it with jack kirby so kevin feige is
just honoring og stan lee when calling the movie
the mutants while they're developing it the title
will probably change before they actually release
it during wandavision billy and tommy are born
to scarlet witch with their powers as mutants
but that happened after marvel got the rights back
to the x-men it was the first example of brand new
mutants coming to the mcu scarlet witch being
a special case like legally they couldn't call
her a mutant until now wandavision which is sort
of the setup for like a full reveal that they'll
do during doctor strange 2 when professor x here
on the illuminati team lays down the full truth
of all existence and mutants to dr strange we
should tell him the truth when professor x says
the multiverse illuminati team here should tell
dr strange the truth he's mostly talking about the
truth of why they're here in this place why the
team exists to protect reality in the multiverse
and the truth about why it's important that they
stop scarlet witch and doctor strange for that
matter from further messing with the multiverse
and through the course of their interactions with
professor x he'll learn what mutants are about
this huge group of humans who were born with
powers in other universes and about the x-men team
from the universe where this professor x came from
there's been a lot of talk about which version of
professor x this is is this the original version
or is he a variant from some other universe the
way i believe the x-men movie producers from the
fox marvel movies explain the wolverine logan
movie is that it was meant to take place in the
very far distant future of the main x-men timeline
long after the events of doctor strange 2 would be
taking place so it's still technically possible
for this version of professor x to be that
original professor x from the fox marvel movies
but my early theory is that he'll wind up being a
variant from a different universe where the events
of the x-men movies in that universe played out
totally differently leading him to depart that
earth enjoying this multiverse illuminati team
because i don't think the original professor x
would just completely bail on his team that way
what this all means though is that some of the
core x-men of the mcu going forward marvel phase
4 marvel phase 5 not all of them but some of them
will be legacy actors from the fox marvel movies
or variants of those characters played by the
same actors and in some cases variants played
by different actors wolverine is a good example
that everybody hoping that hugh jackman eventually
comes back as a version of wolverine in the mcu
there is a rumor that a version of wolverine will
appear in doctor strange 2 as part of all this
craziness but he won't be played by hugh jackman
it'll be some other wolverine variant we've
already seen a couple variants of major avengers
characters in the trailer so it's no surprise
that they would also have variants of other
actors playing some of those x-men characters
too some of the other x-men characters will
also be totally new actors inside the mcu who
were either born with their powers in the mcu
but the x gene just hadn't been activated yet or
they never realized they had powers until present
day or like in the case of billy and tommy they
just hadn't been born until present day the other
obvious answer too is that there have probably
been some x-men characters mutants inside the
mcu that have been keeping themselves hidden this
whole time kind of like the eternals explainer
like have they been here this whole time but we're
not learning about them till now well they're kind
of hiding themselves and talking about the big
house of m twist early scarlet witch theory we
all thought early on during wandavision they were
going to have a reverse house of m moment with
the hex in scarlet witch was going to bring more
mutants to the mcu using the hex but now i think
that they were saving a twist like that for doctor
strange 2because they tend to save all the biggest
wtf moments for the movies so the early theory is
that through the course of the movie scarlet witch
will mess the multiverse up badly enough along
with doctor strange and the other characters
that it will cause multiverse versions of x-men
and mutants legacy actors to start showing up in
the mcu after doctor strange whoever's left alive
on this multiverse illuminati team puts a magical
flex tape on reality what's happening they're
starting to come through and i can't stop him
it's very similar to the ending of spider man
no way home when all those multiverse versions
of sinister six characters started showing up
inside the cracks in reality coming to the mcu
like doctor strange fixed everything with the
spell and theoretically sent all them back to
where they came from but i think after doctor
strange 2 when they patch everything at the end
reality will just be a little bit different like
you put it back together but it's not exactly the
same and that's how they'll bring more x-men
characters into the mcu we also have to talk
about tiamet in the eternals movie my theory about
the way they ended that movie what happened with
tiamet is still the same there's a comic book
run from the past several years where marvel
said that the x gene was created when the blood
of an ancient celestial leeched into earth's soil
just slowly mutating human dna over thousands of
years they can still use teemit for a twist like
that inside the mcu so a massive amount of cosmic
energy was released during that final boss fight
to transform him that massive amount of cosmic
energy could create a bunch of new mutants or
just say that the event activated a bunch of
people's x genes what a coincidence that none
of the marvel phase 4 movies have addressed what
happened with tiamat yet so theoretically doctor
strange 2 and thor 11 thunder which take place
after that would be like the next place where
they could address what happened with tiamat and
how that's going to affect the mcu going forward
but all this means that when marvel puts together
the first legit x-men team in the mcu some of the
people in the movie will be legacy actors from the
multiverse who wanted to come back or variants of
some of those characters and some will be totally
new versions of the characters from inside the mcu
congratulations cameron downing you're the
giveaway winner from my last big marvel video
please email me on the about page of my channel
so i can get your contact details everyone click
here for my full review of the batman movie and
click here for my doctor strange 2 superior iron
man video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!